set a course for Constance if you're
sailing around Lake Constance be sure to
drop anchor here
Constance doesn't just offer visitors a
breathtaking view the city is also rich
in history the imperious statue by the
harbor entrance commemorates the Council
of Constance held here in the Middle
Ages as a local historian explains many
courtesans also came for this ecumenical
conference Davis and I see our Constance
tamatha
we know Constance had 5000 residents at
the time during this church conference
which took place between 14 14 and 14 18
35,000 people of all persuasions and
professions descended upon the town
including some 700 courtesans or the
pretty ones as they were described back
then who plugin and if I had had those
women probably didn't attend discussions
in the Constance Cathedral though
scholars and church leaders from across
the Christian world gathered here to
elect a new pope hoping to put an end to
the divide within the church the
Conclave or election of the Pope took
place here the building in which it was
held normally served a more mundane
purpose I I'm Hank was actually a large
store built in 1388 and the only
election of a pope ever to take place
north of the Alps happened here that was
because unlike the actual council Hall
the Cathedral the store was more secure
it was easier to seal off and keep an
eye on who was coming and going
that's a chameleon Pope Martin v was
elected in this room in 14 17 but now
it's time to raise sales or hop on bikes
and set off for our next destination a
bike path goes right around Lake
Constance from the city of Constance we
head to Russia now with its Benedictine
monastery the island is an agricultural
paradise farming and fishing are a way
of life here
the monks began cultivating the land on
Weiser now centuries ago and agriculture
remains an important source of income to
this day
but the island has other attractions too
with an additional to your own rationale
we have three Romanesque churches that
have survived through the ages now
protected sites on UNESCO's World
Heritage List these churches provide
interesting insights into early medieval
monastic architecture like your thighs
who picked the st. George church was
built in the 9th century and is famous
for its murals that's one reason why I
shall as an important place in the
European art history of this period
visitors device.now should also be sure
not to miss seeing the Church of st.
Peter and st. Paul
there are countless attractions on the
shores of Lake Constance but don't
forget those in the middle of the lake
itself
like my now every year at this time the
island is in full bloom attracting
tourists with over a million flowers the
castle is the island's focal point and
the noble Benedick family still resides
there today some say that the Romans
were here over two thousand years ago
though that's never been proven
conclusively still those interested in
archaeology and history often find what
they're looking for at lake constance
thousands of years ago in the stone and
bronze ages whole settlements here were
built on stilts these lake dwellings
have been reconstructed based on the
latest scientific evidence you can make
a tour of them at the open-air Museum in
until it again Vasa bog boasts an
idyllic looking Peninsula but a very
dark chapter in the town's history took
place in the former law courts here
known as the Mile House fleet allene
altivec shows us where is India we're
here in the darkest corner of our lovely
mal house Chernin my houses in the 17th
century people accused of practicing
witchcraft were held in cells like this
the Allman's osteocyte
oh they left us messages from their time
for example this Christa Graham it means
Jesus savior of mankind or in Latin
gazers hominem Salvatore Salvatore
returning to the present we catch a ride
on a steamboat called felicitous
wherever you're bound on lake constance
you're bound to have a pleasant and
interesting trip